i'm curious i mean one of the great
things about
the office is you know after michael
left
kind of the revolving door of the
different bosses i'm curious from your
perspective
you know meredith seems to be a little
easygoing who do you think was her
favorite boss during that entire time
i'm going to say d'angelo vickers
played by will ferrell that makes sense
that checks out
who do you think was his favorite boss
throughout that entire time at dunder
mifflin probably the person who left him
alone the most is probably
robert california that makes sense
[Music]
happy bates her character was pretty
cool she stayed in her face
yeah because oscar always knew more than
them so he just wanted them to let him
keep going as far as accounting yes i
think
who do you think david wallace's
favorite boss was to work for or work
with
we're oh michael scott come on baby
michael scott easy enough you know i
should have said yes
to the role and threat level midnight
and i should not have sent holly away
i sent holly away because i knew michael
would leave i would have missed him